[Musique]
la commission des affaires sociales que
cela s'est saisi de pouvoir de com sur
une enquête pour voir l'adéquation entre
le pass vaccinale et la situation
sanitaire lors de la première lecture
nous avions mis des critères pour
évaluer ce pass vaccine and ils n'ont
pas été retenue dans le texte donc cette
commission denquête va faire ce travail
inachevé d'allant assez entendre le
directeur général de la santé et le
directeur de cabinet du ministre verrons
nous allons également dit sonné le
professeur delfraissy santé publique
france nous irons dans un hôpital voir
comment sont saisis les patients qui
entrent si ceux qui sont classiques aux
villes qui sont que des accessoires nous
allons également entendre des
partenaires à l'étranger sans doute
anglais et danois nous auditionneront
également l'institut pasteur nous
voulons surveiller un peu comme le lait
sur le feu la situation pour voir si le
pince vaccinale qui est quand même une
contrainte forte doit être et bien en
adéquation que situation sanitaire